la mère m'ouvre et me dire vous venez
voir s'appelle florence vous venez voir
florence elle est sous la douche
non dit en bas je vais revenir elle dit
non parce que moi j'en sors normale
était en peignoir des tac main pas liée
directement ici aussi il ya des
histoires de drague plutôt insolite
concernant les chroniqueurs ici autour
de la table des anecdotes vont
s'afficher sur l'écran vous allez jouer
avec nous également à chez vous pour
essayer de trouver et vous allez c'est
trouver de qui il s'agit voilà autour de
la tap un bien ma tentative de drague a
fini aux urgences
je me suis tapé la vente devant tous mes
amis un ami ma compagne est un rendez
vous merci mme bélanger un abîme
accompagne un rendez vous amoureux il
est reparti avec ma dulcinée
j'ai demandé à ma jumelle de draguer
quelqu'un ma place c'est à dire qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui noël ou un voilà ici
autour de la table il a essayé de me
faire croire qu'il était un grand
baroudeur
la mère de la fille que je draguais a
essayé de se jeter sur moi où je me suis
fait draguer par un commissaire de
police à votre avis qui a eu une
tentative de drague qui a fini aux
urgences
c'est isabelle oury bah oui c'est ça oui
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
exactement les urgences on a dû faire
venir les pompiers
assez pour ça parce que les brevets et
gavé j'avais 17 ans il y avait un mec
qui me draguer mais je savais qu'il
avait des gros bouts l'arrêt qu'il
fallait le séduire intellectuellement et
c'était un fou de master mind donc il
vient chez moi ils savaient pas quoi
dire moi non plus et je lui dis si on se
faisait une partie de master mind bio
mais oui quelle bonne idée ça démarre
bien
on commence à jouer un masque mal et
mousse comme moi je sais pas pourquoi il
dit un jour je t'offrirai un bijou est
comme ça je te mettrai la zone urbaine
on va faire comme avec l'open mastermind
et je mets le club basque à mains à
l'entrée de la narine
je pense au ridicule que j'ai j'éclate
de rire et le pion de masse nord
[Musique]
ce soit des sinus j'essaye de le faire
redescendre délicatement impossible et
puis ça commençait au bout d'une demi
heure j'avais toujours le truc coincé
dans les sinus me faisais semblant ne
pas s'en rendre compte on a dû appeler
les pompiers un jeune pompier beau comme
un dieu
il a dû aller chercher ma chambre avec
une mèche désormis oui il n'ya pas que
le tueur à 6h en pologne est ressorti
avec tous les coups de matos car très
belle histoire
on était trois potes et puis on tombe
sur un groupe de quatre filles ouais
peut-être fille est un pote sort avec
une fille de ce groupe là est le
deuxième euro perd une fille aussi d'un
groupe de quatre filles il les trouve
vraiment pas mal du tout et il réussit à
la branche est donc naturellement je me
dis le reste de feu mais j'ai barré à la
troisième elle a fait avant certainement
pas
j'étais en première ou en terminale et
je voulais aller au cinéma avec la fille
que je voulais draguer donner un peu de
force était un peu timide j'y suis allée
que mon meilleur ami et c'est lui qui
l'a emballé au cinéma qui est reparti
avec c'est l'histoire de votre vie sain
[Musique]
je devais porter plainte ce que je
m'étais fait voler un scooter et
j'arrive au commissariat tout se passe
bien le commissaire arrive et je sens
vraiment que je lui tape dans l'oeil
une donne donne ça car genre vraiment si
vous avez le moindre problème juif et
deux jours après le commissaire
m'appelle en ne convoquant les
infractions vous revenez au commissariat
nous avons un gros problème par rapport
aux vols de scooters et tout j'y vais je
ne comprends pas l'intérêt du rendez
vous puisque je passe une heure dans le
bureau le mec me raconte toute sa vie
mais vraiment depuis sa naissance
jusqu'à sa note de l'essence un peu
visiblement torturé
bon je m'en vais je me dis ok sympa
j'ose pas l'envoyer paître parce qu'il
est commissaire
le lendemain ils rappellent ils avaient
boudé mais revenez on a trouvé l'homme
idéal au ces les commissaires à la
mairie je reviens encore le surlendemain
parce qu'il m'avait fait croire qu'on
avait retrouvé mon scooter rien du tout
et là le mec concrètement me demande un
rendez-vous galant en place entre quatre
murs avec la secrétaire à côté cette zac
et je l'avais envoyé balader et depuis
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de contraventions
génère bien le gars j'aime bien le gars
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors j'étais
très amoureux j'arrive pour l'avoir à
vélo je retire mes pinceaux haye et à
vélo je pense je fasse à l'appartenance
était heureux autant que les siècles
déjà à vélo j'étais jeune j'étais jeune
j'avais 18 19 ans donc je frappe et là
j'allais la voir la mer m'ouvre de ma
future conquête j'espérais la mer
m'ouvre et me dire vous venez voir
s'appelle florence vous venez voir
florence elle est sous la douche
non dix ans ben je vais revenir elle dit
non parce que moi j'en sors non mais là
l'été en peignoir des tac mon panier
direct non directement
c'est tony parker
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ose dire que c'est parmi tout au plus
à hasnon mais je le crois parce que ça
cesse alors est donc très belle femme et
j'étais impressionné les tempes et mal
retire le peignoir me prend par les
l'aller les parties m'emmène sur le
canapé mais oui et là je vibre et votre
finale mondiale est sous la douche
elle passe énormément de temps sur la
douche waouh et erreurs et j'ai passé
des noms et je suis reparti philippe
vous êtes vous être accusé deux ans j'ai
eu ni la mère ni la fille
[Musique]